if you truly are a friend and you love
somebody you encourage them to fulfill
their dreams
and i always do that to my students i
always felt like you have a dream
and you're afraid of accomplishing it
what if your dream is the most important
dream that ever came along in the human
race and you don't do anything about it
it was your dream and you do nothing
about it to me that's a sacrilege
you know you you had the dream for a
reason you know it's in your mind for a
reason either god put it there or
it was born in your mind from some other
source
why aren't you going to do something
about it well because i'm afraid that
my father and mother would be really
upset and i go so this is a hypothetical
fear
about something that hasn't happened yet
right
yes then why not just do it and deal
with
the possibility that may never happen at
all
and that's it's a matter of knowing
yourself